exactly three weeks ago today as major
American cities were consumed by rioting
and looting Jill Biden delivered this
message the country is crying out for
leadership leadership the q9s leadership
that brings us together we stand
together finally as one America will
rise stronger than we were before we'll
move that heart closer to justice now no
one who has studied politics longer than
about five minutes really believes this
now Biden has been in office for what
40-plus years so what is he even
spending his time doing and I could've
sworn a buddy of his promise to do all
this
what was that 12 years ago I'm
absolutely certain that generations from
now we will be able to look back and
tell our children that this was the
moment when we began to provide care for
the sick and good job
the jobless this was the moment when the
rise of the oceans began to slow and our
planet began to heal what the planet was
starting to heal what the heck happened
well I guess Joe's kind of admitting
that none of that worked out and I can
say tonight if Obama with his star power
and political skill couldn't do any of
that lord knows Joe can't he couldn't
lead a retirement home sing-along let
alone the largest military superpower on
earth a unifying force he is not evident
just in the past three weeks when
Biden's campaign has tacitly thrown in
with the Marxist BL eminent Aoife forces
they're taking radical violent action to
do it Obama pledged he would do through
policy making in 2008 remake America now
in this case if it requires disrupting
elections they'll do it if it requires
intimidating businesses and individuals
to pledge their money and loyalty to
this twisted mission they'll do it if it
requires allowing anarchists to burn
buildings desecrate churches destroy art
literature movies monuments rename towns
and cities and even the country itself
they'll do it and as this mayhem has
been carried out coast-to-coast we've
heard nary a peep from Joe Biden who was
obviously incapable of truly campaigning
in the traditional sense statues of
presidents revered even by Obama himself
are being pulled down now this is all
sheer insanity I know you wake up in the
morning and you say oh my god what kind
of country what is it what country is
this I'm living in it's like some
dystopian movie you're watching over and
over again and that's the way most
normal Americans feel but it's all
necessary this this.k of chaos and ma'am
if your goal is to start the nation over
begin at all at day zero they believe
you have to annihilate the old
traditions to prime the population for a
new normal Biden to the extent he even
understands what's going on at all seems
totally fine with this and
after one of their most tedious mantras
his silence is violence violence against
the political historical and cultural
landmarks of our nation Joe says nothing
when day after day these macchiato
Maoists are taking over city blocks
terrorizing small business owners
assaulting innocent Americans just
because they can he says he supports the
good police officers out there but he's
mute when videos fly around social media
like these she sound like a lot of fun
on a Saturday night do you know why
Biden doesn't speak out forcefully
against any of this because he can't
afford to offend these hemp wearing
nasties they're the closest thing he has
to a national campaign base they have
energy they're well-organized they're
well funded and they do what Biden
himself will not do they'll fly all over
America to mix it up and they'll try to
bait donald trump into action they'll
all vote for Biden of course they will
none of them are gonna vote for Trump
and Biden's just fine with that he needs
that in fact one of ITINs only attempts
to condemn the violence and destruction
was way back on May 31st he said we're a
nation in pain but we must not allow
this pain to destroy us we're a nation
exhausted but we will not allow our
exhaustion to defeat us weak tepid
pro-forma corn pop would have done a
more convincing job than that the
National Police Officers Association is
abandoning Biden which is especially
stunning since its members only backed
Obama in 2008 in 2012
because Biden was on the ticket now
Biden's silence
well it just emboldened people like this
please make sure you treat them like the
main point the main point that everyone
watching this tonight needs to
understand really clearly Biden equals
chaos his campaign team thinks that he
can ride this violent anarchy into power
right into the White House again but far
from being a uniting force a Biden
presidency would usher in a time of
division and distrust unlike anything
we've experienced in our lifetimes even
worse than what's happening right now
because his election will not lead to
more calm but it's going to lead to
unrest not just in our beleaguered
cities but everywhere and it's gonna
follow you into your place of work into
your place of worship into your kids
schools his entire appeal to moderate
voters is that
well Biden's this nice old man who will
have a calming effect during these
turbulent times but electing him will
not satisfy the violent radicals it will
only embolden them and their aim is to
undermine our faith in essential
institutions and our founding principles
well the American people really allow
that to happen I highly highly highly
doubt it
this will require that President Trump
speak confidently about his plans for
the future how things are already
getting better
how Biden will make things worse and
more toxic and how we're still one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all and he's
just getting started and that's the
angle